Це минулорічна нарада у Володимира Зеленського з підготовки держбюджету-2020.
Тоді президент писав на своїй сторінці у Фейсбук, що поставив завдання скоротити видатки
на утримання чиновників на 10 відсотків.
Мовляв, це дозволить зекономити кошти та направити їх на соціально важливі статті бюджету.
Минув рік і в проєкті держбюджету на 2021-й вже планується закласти значно більше коштів
на фінансування центральних органів влади.
Зокрема, вперше за останні роки видатки на роботу Офісу президента мають перевищити один мільярд гривень.
У 2019-му, в останній рік президентства Порошенка, на його адміністрацію витратили трохи більше 900 мільйонів гривень.
Приблизно стільки ж має бути витрачено і у 2020-му - в перший рік президентства Зеленського.
А от на наступний рік вже закладається на 357 мільйонів гривень більше.
На що мають бути витрачені ці гроші?
У проєкті держбюджету сказано, що на "обслуговування та організаційне, інформаційно-аналітичне,
матеріально-технічне забезпечення президента України та Офісу президента України".
Йдеться, зокрема, і про видатки на перельоти та кортежі глави держави.
Додатково, згідно з даними Офісу президента, з бюджету фінансується утримання держдачі у Конча-Заспі,
куди нещодавно після ремонту переїхав президент з родиною.
Хоча напередодні вирішального другого туру президентських виборів у квітні 2019-го
Зеленський запевняв, що не буде користуватися державними резиденціями.
Нехай в цих резиденціях живуть дітки якісь. Я от не знаю, як це зараз називається.
Декомунізували ж назву піонер-табір, правильно? Табір відпочинку?
Вони якось самі собою декомунізувались.
- Так, вже давно. Ну, якісь табори відпочинку або якісь люди, яким це дійсно потрібно.
А ось ці резиденції - я не бачу в них взагалі жодного сенсу.
У зв'язку з чим зростають видатки на діяльність Зеленського в держбюджеті на наступний рік
і на що планується витратити отримані кошти?
На відповідний запит DW, відправлений понад місяць тому до Офісу президента,
відповіді на момент публікації цього відео так і не надійшло.
Водночас в уряді пояснюють збільшення в проєкті держбюджету видатків на діяльність Зеленського
та його апарату диспропорцією у заробітних платах.
За словами міністра фінансів Сергія Марченка, це не зрада, а турбота про працівників Офісу президента.
Мовляв, Мінфін побачив, що рівень зарплат службовців, які працюють в Офісі президента,
порівнюючи з секретаріатом Кабміну та апаратом Верховної Ради, значно нижчий.
На сайті президента України також оприлюднили заяву керівника його офісу Андрія Єрмака,
в якій він закликає урядовців та нардепів скоротити видатки на утримання органів державної влади.
А якщо буде неможливо зменшити інші видатки, президент готовий скоротити 10 відсотків працівників свого офісу.
Цього року через пандемію коронавірусу в Україні та світі президент значно менше літав з візитами.
Відповідно, було заощаджено гроші, закладені у бюджеті на 2020-ий.
Чи перенесуть зекономлені кошти на наступний рік, невідомо. Адже Державне управління справами,
яке забезпечує діяльність президента, могло перерозподілити заощаджені гроші та витратити їх на інші потреби.
На які саме, з'ясується вже після закінчення нинішнього бюджетного року.
Однією з причин збільшення видатків на роботу Офісу президента могла би бути різниця курсу гривні до долара та євро.
Оскільки, наприклад, закордонні візити дорожчають, відповідно зростає сума видатків у гривнях.
Так рік тому, за даними Нацбанку, долар коштував 24,7 гривні, а нині понад 28. Різниця - 13 відсотків.
Утім, видатки на діяльність президента та його офісу планують збільшити значно більше - на майже 40 відсотків.
Крім того, два роки тому долар коштував майже стільки ж, як і зараз.
У проєкті держбюджету на наступний рік закладено курс 29 гривень за один долар і дефіцит бюджету 270 мільярдів гривень.
За словами експертів, цю суму доведеться покривати позиками МВФ
та інших міжнародних донорів або друкувати нові гривні.